endstation knast gangsta-rapper dieses
wurde heute zu einer gefängnisstrafe
verurteilt
er ist einer der bekanntesten aber auch
berüchtigsten rapper deutschlands
mussten sich dieses mal wieder vor
gericht verantworten unter anderem wegen
verstößen gegen das waffengesetz
drogenbesitz und körperverletzung aber
nicht vor gericht zeigte er sich von
seiner besten seite
heute ist dann das urteil gefallen den
prozess hat für uns beobachtet dino
schröder mir nun auch aus hamburg
zugeschaltet
was genau ist denn jetzt das urteil
gegen gianni leute war es soweit ein
jahr sechs monate dazu 510.000 euro
es gab auch noch abwarten für den
verteidiger christopher posch da der
richter züge sagt ja wenn sie sich
besser vorbereitet während 300.000 euro
weniger gewesen
anderthalb jahre knast für dieses heißt
es er muss jetzt sofort ins gefängnis
nein es muss ja nicht er hat natürlich
sofort berufung eingelegt da gab es auch
gleich in dieses punkte hatten die
berufung auch schon vorbereitet
schriftlich wollten sie dem richter
gleich geben sei gesagt nein gehen sie
mal aus geschäftszimmer da sie gelandet
also dieses bleibt auf freiem fuß es
gibt wäre es wird weitergehen vor dem
landgericht hamburg war seine heute
reaktion trotzdem auf dieses urteil hat
sich so schlecht benommen wie immer also
man kann sich das kaum vorstellen
also heute war es so und natürlich der
richter hat mich sehr ausführlich das
urteil begründet und zwischendurch
machte dieses dann die aussage bereit
sich manchmal weiter wir haben keine
zeit also er ist dieses ist
beratungsresistent das muss man einfach
sagen und mit seinem verteidiger war
glaube ich auch schlecht aufgestellt und
was gerade gesagt so schlecht benommen
wie immer er ist ja während des prozess
sogar schon mal rausgeflogen für den tag
dazu vorbestraft saß bereits im
gefängnis sind das auch die gründe dafür
dass jetzt das gericht eine schwere
strafe verhängt hat als eigentlich
gefordert die staatsanwaltschaft wollte
14 monate für dieses vollkommen richtig
also übertreten der amtsrichter ist
bekannt
seine harte hand will ich mal sagen und
auch hier hat er deutlich gemacht dass
das so nicht geht natürlich dieses
gesagt man muss sich die frage stellen
wer muss in den knast wenn nicht sie
bezeichnet sich als sozial rübel
er sagte zu ihm sie generieren sich als
gangsta rapper und landen sie im
gefängnis das sagt also einiges dazu gab
es auch eine abwarten für den
verteidiger zudem meinte ja sie spielen
hier im gericht schiffe versenken das
einzige was sie versenkt haben ist ihren
eigenen mandanten sind sehr deutliche
worte wir sind also gespannt wie es dann
in der nächsten instanz weiter geht und
ob der rapper dieses dann tatsächlich
ins gefängnis muss vielen dank dino
schröder aus hamburg erst mal mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dir das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren